As temperatures continue to rise and
natural disasters grow in frequency and
magnitude, tens of millions across the
country are forced to grapple with
what's becoming the new normal. The
world is nuts right now.
The Bible has been talking about this
forever.
These are the signs. The disciples
wanted to know these signs. They wanted
to know what was going to be happening
right before Jesus came so they could be
prepared.
God went to a great length to preserve
Bible prophecy for us so that we would
have a heads up as to what we can expect
in the time before Jesus. Pope Francis
is com is condemning world leaders the
US for failing to address climate
change. The message that needs to be
broadcast from every hill and mountain
is a message about the life-saving
Jesus,
not the life-saving paper straw. change
every Why isn't Jesus coming here? When
is he coming?
I don't know when Jesus is coming, but I
know that today we're one day closer.
Pastor Jamie, so great to have you
aboard here. Let me tell you, this guy
and his family has had a huge impact on
my life. They were the ones that
interviewed Roger Mno in the beginning.
And uh you're like a bit of a celebrity.
I love it. I'm I'm glad that you were
able to come by, but but he's also my
pastor. I go to his church. been blessed
by your work. He is a podcaster as well
and stuff. So, um I think you're going
to like this conversation. We're going
to get into a little bit of this crazy
stuff that we're seeing in the world
today, but welcome aboard. Thank you.
Thank you. It's good to be here. Yeah.
So, tell us a little bit about like, you
know, what what's really, you know,
under the surface here that that we need
to be talking about this subject. Yeah.
I've I've like everybody, we've all seen
so much in the media and so many
different pushes about the climate. I
can remember when I was younger there
was all kinds of talk about the ozone
layer and people were like, "Hey, let's
switch from paper bags to plastic bags."
And then now it's like a switch. Okay,
we're back from plastic bags to paper
bags and everybody right paper straws.
And uh by the way, worst idea ever.
That's the worst idea ever. Yeah.
Whenever somebody just has paper straws,
I'm like, "Come on, give me plastic
straws." Well, it's funny is I saw a
video that broke down. They're like, "So
they sell you the the food in plastic.
They have so many plastic things, but
they're worried about the bags and the
paper straws. Exactly. Interesting. But
we hear so much about this stuff.
There's there's all kinds of meetings
where people meet all over the world.
Our government leaders get together and
try and put different agendas together
for how we're all going to do this. And
you hear phrases like, "Well, we're all
in this together." And we're like, well,
we've heard that before. Um, but we're
we're going to be we're And another one
is is this is our common home and we've
got to take care of this and stuff. And
so with so much emphasis on on the
climate and and what we're doing and how
we're going to save the planet and
things like that, it's always just made
me think of of what the Bible says. We
have so many different people predicting
the end of the world. Um you'll see it
in the news where where people like AOC
will be like, "Hey, we've got 12 years."
Or Al Gore has been super vocal about
this and and saying, "Hey, Bill Gates."
Bill Gates as well. Yeah. So many people
doomsday clock. Yeah. Yeah. Isn't there
a doomsday clock that they're actually
thinking? Yeah. And so it's it's really
a big big topic of conversation where
big voices, you have a lot of Hollywood
people that are talking about this. Um
even though it's not really their
expertise and uh and somehow we had what
was she 12 years old, Greta Thunderberg.
Um and people are like, "Let's listen to
her." And you're like, "Well, maybe we
should listen to people with a PhD
instead." I don't know. And also if I
can pitch in there, the pope, like what
does he know about this? his encyclical
was in this area, wasn't it? Yeah. So,
so like everybody has like a thing that
they're into, you know, every pastor
kind of has this one thing that they're
that they're pushing or promoting or
whatever like that, but that that's his
thing is the climate change. Yeah. And
you know, as as I look at
this, I've seen the pictures of of um
receding glaciers and stuff. Yeah, I've
seen it and and it's legit. there's
there's something going on here. But
I've also but here's the conflicting
thing is because we also see um and and
there's a lot of people that criticize
the the climate agenda people because
you know the people that are saying hey
that the ocean's going to raise by like
3 feet and you're like well you just
bought a an oceanfront mansion so how
legit are you really believing this
stuff? Um but at the same time there is
an increase in natural disasters and
different things. I was we were talking
a little bit before and um there's the
emergency assistance foundation and
ecological threat register for 2020
report. This is this is kind of
interesting cuz it's at the same time
that there are are questions there are
some legitimate concerns that we have to
look at. It says um we are 10 times we
have 10 times as many natural disasters
today compared to 1960. Wow. That's a
lot. 10 times. They also said that it's
uh we've had a 35% increase in natural
disasters since 1990. That's not that
long ago. Wow. Um so so we are seeing an
increase in this stuff. Um they said in
2021 one in three Americans faced a
weather related disaster.
One in three
a lot of the parts of the country then.
Yeah. We some of my friends we've we've
looked at at a map of the United States
and said all right where where's the
safest place to live? I grew up in San
Diego and we'd have earthquakes all the
time. Um the desert. Yeah. Yeah. I mean
I I can remember the whole house shaking
and and um we had earthquake drills in
school where we hang on to the legs of
our desks and stuff, but then there's
tornadoes. Florida people have said,
"Hey, Jamie, you should move to
Florida." I'm like, "They have a whole
season for hurricanes." I'm from
Florida. Yeah. Not not the best. I'm
like, man, they have a season for it. I
want to see a twister, though. Do you? I
do. like when they said it was coming
this last like month or week or a couple
weeks ago, I was outside with my phone.
I was like, I'm gonna see this puppy. I
don't I don't get that. I'm not from
from Tennessee. And so I've I've talked
to to some of my church members and when
you know we have tornado warnings and
stuff and I'm like, so you guys have
basements and they're like, "Oh no, we
just go get some sweet tea and go out on
the front porch and watch for." And I'm
like, "What? Seriously?"
That's crazy. But but you know, the
reality is is there is a lot more
activity. Yeah. And so, you know, as as
we look at at the people that are that
are ringing alarm bells,
I I look at what their message is. What
is the message of the media today, of
politicians, celebrities? What is their
message in regards to this? Because the
Bible talks about the climate. Mhm. But
it's a very different message that we
get from the Bible than what we get on
Fox or CNN or or um you know any of
these entertainment uh platforms. Mhm.
The message that we get in the news
today is we need to use paper straws so
we can stay here longer. We've got to
save the planet. But we're saving the
planet by doing something ourselves.
Right. Right. Interesting. That's a good
point. And that's not what the Bible
says. What does the Bible say? Mhm. So,
so before you go there, it does say in
Genesis when God made the earth, he
said, "You're the stewards of the earth.
Take care of it." For sure. So, I can
imagine that some Christians might quote
that and be like, "Well, we are supposed
to take care of it." You know, we are
supposed to recycle our trash, which
which here in Tennessee is where I from
is not really done. There's no option,
right? But but um you are supposed to do
these things. So, how do you look at
that? But then we also look at like
you're saying, I agree with you. Yeah.
that we're not supposed to try to stay
here longer, etc. I I bet you when we
get to heaven and we look back on this,
what happened on this thing? They're
doing this. I think they're they're
actually causing a lot. I mean, Satan
can and has the ability to mess with the
weather at least in in in some form. We
know it just happened um where in the
news it was talking about COVID that it
was actually coming from a lab. This was
generic news. This is not like a back
off hand like some person in the back
woods. this was generic mainstream news,
you know. So, yeah, I I agree with you.
I believe it. Yeah, we have to I think
we have to take care of things. That's
that's a responsible thing to do for
sure. You know, don't throw your trash
out the window when you're driving. For
sure. Recycle if you can and things like
that. Isn't that the basic law of heaven
to think about other people in what
however you're treating this? So, yeah,
if you're just like dumping your car
motor oil out down the drain, yeah,
there's a problem with that, right?
There's a responsibility that we have
here to take care of God's beautiful
earth that he's created for us. Um, but
the the emphasis that's taken on that
goes in two different directions.
There's one that focuses on on heavenly
things and God things and there's one
that focuses on self-reliance.
And that's that's where I see the
difference here.
And in in this grand scheme of things in
humanity, the message that needs to be
broadcast from from every hill and
mountain is a message about the
life-saving Jesus.
Not the life-saving paper straw. Amen.
Amen. And so, you know, as I as I look
at this world and the hot mess that it
is, the suffering that goes on here, the
the message that needs to be sent out is
about Jesus and how he can help us and
save us and has a better place for us.
Amen. Prepared. And so, you know, you
don't have to look far to see a lot of
suffering in this world. Right. Right.
And and the amount of abuse that goes
on, it's staggering.
And the only hope that bring that people
have is in Jesus not staying here
longer. Now I'm I'm reminded in Matthew
24. I I really enjoy Matthew 24 as a
chapter because it it has it's like a
compass that points us as as humanity
where we're going. Pay attention to
these things. Right. Yeah. And and I
just want to read a little bit in
Matthew 24 starting in verse three. The
disciples were were curious. They've
been listening to Jesus and they're
like, "Hey, what are some of the signs
for when you're going to come?" Here's
what Jesus said. And and I'm fascinated
with the first thing that he says before
he gets into any specific signs. He says
this to his disciples. Take heed or pay
attention that no one deceives you. It's
the first thing he says. He doesn't say
anything about like um like like
specific signs. The first thing he says
is be careful. There are going to be
elements that are trying to deceive you.
Mhm. Mhm. Pay attention to the truth is
what he's saying. Then he says, "For
many will come in my name, saying, I am
the Christ. You will hear of wars and
rumors of wars." That's we hear all the
time. Yeah. That's like a daily thing,
right? Um then he says, "See that you
are not troubled. All these things must
come to pass, but the end is not yet.
For nation will rise against nation and
kingdom against kingdom. There will be
famines, pestilences, and earthquakes in
various places." Jesus is saying that in
the time right before he comes, things
are going to be shaken up in a lot of
different ways. And he says, "All these
things are the beginning of sorrows.
Then they will deliver you up in
tribulation and kill you and you'll be
hated by the nations for my name's
sake." And this is one of the funniest
of Jesus predictions of end time um
signs. He says, "And many people will be
offended." Yeah. But but it's so true
today. Everyone is offended on
everything. Everything. It's never been
easier to find people who who've been
offended. What What happened to the art
of us talking about things? Just just
having a discussion like this and bring
it out on the table. Here's some
information and we need to think about
this. I mean, it's just like people are
like, you don't believe like this, you
know, you just I'm not going to listen
to you. Everybody's offended. You
doesn't matter what you say. Somebody's
offended. And Jesus was like, yeah, this
is coming. Whatever you say, somebody's
going to be offended. I just I always
thought that was funny that Jesus threw
that in there cuz there's a whole lot of
heavy stuff and he's like by the way
good point doesn't matter what you say
somebody's going to be upset. Um he says
he continues says they will betray one
another and will hate one another then
many false prophets will arise and
deceive many and because lawlessness
will abound the love of many will grow
cold but he who endures the end will be
saved. And this is one of my favorite
verses in verse 14 because it tells us
that the world's not going to end
because of climate change 100%. Mhm. He
says, "And the gospel of the kingdom
will be preached into all the world as a
witness to all the nations, and then the
end will come."
That takes the whole message of this
climate emergency and it gives me
clarity
because I know the world's not going to
end because the temperature raises one
and a half degrees. I've always thought
that when they said a meteor could
potentially come and hit the earth, and
it's like, no, that's not how this
thing's going to end. Like, what a what
a weak sauce ending, you know? And
that's been in the news in the last
couple of weeks. Yeah. Yeah. I thought I
found it interesting what you're saying
here because when our focus is, oh, the
world's going to come to an end to clim
due to climate change. Let's stay here
longer while sin is getting worse.
That's taking the focus off of what is
our message. Yeah. Is Revelation 14.
It's the three angels messages. It's
this here is a distraction from this
totally sharing the gospel and telling
people. It's it's the um midnight cry,
you know, from the that we see in the
parable of the virgins that Jesus is
coming soon, the king is coming. That
should be our message, right? Yeah.
Ready yourself.
And and the message here in these very
important days is not a bring yourself
closer to God. There's no repentance. M
it's just in fact in fact the message
today is um it doesn't matter what you
do even if it's bad that's just who you
are or what you do and there's no
accountability and and um which is the
exact opposite of what we need to be
doing in the time before Jesus. There's
a there's a quote from one of my
favorite authors that that has to do
with with um what we're talking about
and and she says this. She says the
restraining spirit of God is even now
being withdrawn from the world.
Hurricanes, storms, tempests, fire and
flood, disasters by sea and land follow
each other in quick succession. Science
seeks to explain all these things. Just
like we see today, everyone's like,
"Well, let's look at the science of this
and whatever." Which, by the way,
there's different scientists with
different perspectives on this, which is
interesting to hear, too. But it all
seems to muddy the water. Nobody really
can say specifically, but she says here,
"Science seeks to explain all these
things. The signs thickening around us
telling of the near approach of the son
of God are attributed to any other than
the true cause.
And I see this as a as a massive
distraction like what you were talking
about here where it's it's kind of a
curveball. The Bible has been talking
about this forever. Mhm. These are the
signs. The disciples wanted to know
these signs. They wanted to know what
was going to be happening right before
Jesus came so they could be prepared.
Mhm. Mhm. And I think that's what Jesus
the purpose of him giving us these
things so that we could be prepared. But
yet people are saying, "Hey, let's see
what the science says about this." Why?
And explain all these different things
from science where Jesus had
specifically said, "Hey, there's going
to be a lot of wild stuff going on in
the world." Even specifically mentions
earthquakes and and things like that
that would kind of shake us up a little
bit. And um I think people in general
are looking in the wrong direction.
Yeah. It's a way to sort of like smoking
mirrors, right? Right. just a little bit
of distraction over here, focus on this
and you know this this thing we can you
know fix and work out. I remember Walter
Vice he said something in in one of his
meetings one time. He was breaking down
like you know this whole idea of the
carbon footprint and and you know he was
basically making the point of like what
do plants eat? Mhm. Oh they they eat
carbon dioxide and stuff like that,
right? And they turn it around and give
it oxygen. So what happens if you give
them more food? There's more plants and
then they produce more oxygen. And so
it's like to remove all of the carbon
stuff like this. It's like you're
removing the plant food. Yeah.
Essentially, I mean, that that was kind
of a revolutionary thought to me. I was
like, "Oh, yeah. If you if you really
have a lot of this stuff, you know,
getting worse and worse and worse, I God
made a system that's going to, you know,
deal with it." Yeah. Yeah. you know, the
um it's interesting that there's like
you were talking about earlier, there's
a lot of religious people that talk
about climate change and um and before
this this was um this was back when they
had the climate um meetings in Glasgow.
And it always kind of cracks me up too
that when people have these climate
meetings, everybody's like, "Let's take
our private jets, right?" Like, "Hey, I
need to get there." Yeah. Yeah. Like
those celebrities are all like, "Climate
change and it's like, well, they're
flying massive private jets." Yeah.
There are carbon footprints like that of
150 people or something like multiple
jets. Okay. So, what about all the
factories that that are pumping this
stuff out that are like, okay, we'll
clean stuff up by 2035, you know, and
it's like, oh, so you don't believe in
it that much to the point that you need
to fix it, right? Yeah. The hypocrisy
that you see in all this really makes
people like I I don't weary when when I
still think that we should be good
stewards of what God made us. But it
it's just I think it makes people sick
and tired of hearing about it and seeing
because everybody hates hypocrisy. Yeah.
And so people are just like well let's
stop talking about it. But you know so
politics and religion these two things
are are talking about this at an
increasing rate. Yeah. What are they
gearing up for? And and what what blows
my mind too is that the those in the
religious world that are talking about
this stuff really ignore the second
coming as well. They kind of they kind
of take on the secular viewpoint of
global warming and whatever else the
climate change stuff. Um and and really
you don't hear many people preaching
about the second coming of Jesus even in
Christianity today. Right. Right. And
this even even by some of these
religions is is pointing us to stay here
longer. That's that's the goal of some
of this stuff. There was an article um
in the Guardian. I believe it's out of
um the UK somewhere uh 200-y old
newspaper, an article by a guy named
Satish Kumar. And uh his his article is
called Slow Sunday, the simple solution
to global
warming. And you're like, "Wait a
second, wait a second. Okay. The
solution to global warming is worshiping
on Sunday." Yeah. Or or honoring Sunday
somehow. And and the the subtitle says,
"Using Sunday as a day of rest and
renewal would be good for our personal
health as well as the health of the
planet." So it's not a new idea. It's
been around for a while. Yeah. And we
see we see these climate Sundays. We
were talking a little bit about that.
Yeah. Green Sabbath. Green Sabbath.
That's another big movement. Um so their
purpose is to collectively halt the
activity because if you if you made it
random like, well, you can just pick one
day. Don't do this on one day. You know,
you can choose whatever day you want,
right? Mhm. There's still businesses
that have to operate. So, they've really
got a clever angle with saying if
everybody ceases now, the restaurants,
the grocery stores, the everything like
this, just like you can't do those
things, you know? Yeah. Yeah. I remember
watching a documentary uh on Netflix, a
nature documentary. It was around the
time of CO when it was still around and
it actually pointed out, oh, when when
CO happened, everything was shut down.
nature thrived and therefore we should
have this on one day a week which is
Sunday. I was like what? Yeah. Like why
not any other day of the week, right?
that we understand where prophecy is
headed and like you're saying, you know,
as Christians, we shouldn't be so
focused on keeping ourselves here and on
the climate because I believe that's one
of the flavors that will push us toward
unfortunately the mark of the beast as
we understand which we have videos link
in the description. What is the mark of
the beast and what is the antichrist
power? If you want to know more, check
it out. It's coring the sheep. Mhm. It's
a kind of like sending them off in a
direction that's like you're building
the fence for them to get to there. And
and it's a departure from from the
scriptures. That's that's my biggest
problem with a lot of these different
ideas is that it's not faithful to the
Bible. Mhm. And you know in in
Revelation it talks about those that are
faithful in the end and it says they
will be commandment keepers. That's
right. It specifically multiple times
brings up the importance of being
commandment keepers. Yeah. And and part
of that has to do with the Sabbath, the
seventh day Sabbath. Mhm. And so Yeah.
Nice. I love the shirt.
I noticed that when I got wore the shirt
on a good day. Sabbath. Love it. And so
the the switch from from Sabbath to
Sunday has been something that's been
documented throughout um throughout
history. You guys may have some some
videos on it. I've I've done some
videos. It's a historical event, you
know, that happened, right? And and a a
departure from scripture because we see
multiple times even in the New Testament
after the resurrection of Jesus where
the the disciples were still keeping the
seventh day Sabbath. Yeah. It even says
in the scriptures that uh you know Jesus
I think it might also be in Matthew 24
where he says pray that your flight and
he's referring to the last days before
he comes back shall not be on the
Sabbath day. Why would that be if we're
not keeping the Sabbath anymore? I mean,
Isaiah even talks about the Sabbath
being kept in heaven. Revelation talks
about um I think it's um John being on
the the day of the Lord when he wrote
it. No, no. Revelation 14, is it 14:12?
I think um where it talks about uh that
there shall be a a people who who will
keep the commandments of God. Um you
know,
in it's the only commandment God said to
remember. Yeah. He never said, "Remember
not to kill people." Right? That that
one's kind of kind of solid. We we know
that one. Remember, he never said,
"Remember to honor your parents," which
is a good thing to do, but he didn't
say, "Remember that one." The only one
he said to remember, it seems like the
whole world has forgotten. Yeah. And so
we see we see um more religion getting
involved in this. The um the Laoato C
authored by Pope Francis in 2015, he
talks about the climate extensively and
he has three solutions to help deal with
the climate. And it kind of goes along
with what you were talking about in the
co stuff. He said, "Uh, we should car
pool." All right. You know, that might
help. Um, he says, "Turn off the air
conditioning. That's not going to go
over well for folks in Phoenix." Yeah.
Or Florida. Yeah. Or us in about 3
months, two months. But the third the
third solution that he had for dealing
with climate change was giving the
planet a Sunday rest. Mhm. Mhm. Mhm. And
we keep seeing that thing being pushed
throughout Christianity, which again
just belittles the importance of the
seventh day Sabbath that we see in the
Bible. That is a a reminder of our
creator God. Yeah. And points us back to
creation. Yeah. And and you know, I I
just that makes me super uncomfortable.
Yeah. It's a divergence from from
scripture. And anytime I see that, I
think to myself, all right,
why would someone change up what God has
set up? Because if you don't go along
with what they're saying, you don't care
about the fellow man. And there's a
whole chain of events that that trickle
down the line from that that like, you
know, you can see how they are actually
setting it up to the point where you're
going to get in trouble if you're not
spending that day. We see this in
Jesus's time. the the Pharisees who were
um Christians at the time, Christian
leaders were saying, "Well, it's better
for one man to die than for a whole
nation to suffer, so let's do kill you
so we're fine." Mhm. Yeah.
I'm sorry. Do we know each other? It
seems like maybe we've met before. I
don't know. This is uh it's awkward
though, just as much for me as it is for
you. I really wish I had a conversation
starter. Oh, hey. Oh, what's on my
shirt? Yeah, this is the story of the
three angels message from Revelation 14.
Wow, that totally worked. You know, if
you have trouble starting conversations
like me, maybe you should try LightWare.
[Music]
This, I think, is a call for us to
biblical faithfulness. Amen.
um and and to really do a deep dive each
one of us um into the scriptures because
God went to a whole to a great length to
preserve Bible prophecy for us so that
we would have a heads up as to what we
can expect in the time before Jesus
comes. Yeah. Because it would be not a
good thing if like you were never told.
You were you just hit this thing
blindsided. Yeah. I mean, what a
merciful thing for God to do and say,
"I'm going to give you like what's going
to happen so you know why it's
happening." Right. Right. And and that
also helps us know what not to expect.
And to clear up um the details of these
things because remember the first thing
that Jesus said to his disciples in all
of this conversation about end times was
be careful that you're not deceived.
Amen. Because he knew that the devil
would go around like a roaring lion
seeking whom he could destroy. Mhm. The
devil is a master at deceiving people.
And his deceptions are pretty pretty
believable a lot of times. And so Jesus
knew that and said, "Hey, be careful.
Know what I'm telling you. Know the
scriptures. Study the Bible prophecies
and then you'll be aware of what to
watch for and you'll know the difference
between the truth and a lie." Amen.
They're pushing towards peace and
safety. So Thessalonians, you know,
chapter 5, 2 Thessalonians, that's where
it says, you know, um they're going to
say peace and safety and then sudden
destruction comes upon them. So the
picture that the Bible does give, yes,
it tells you that this is going to get
worse and worse. Yeah. Not that we're
turning this around. Yeah. And for for
the viewers at home, we have uh an
online Bible school where you can go
through all these prophecies.
lls.tv/bible school. It's for free. So
check it out. And again, we'll drop a
bunch of videos in description as well
for you to watch. You said something
cool that we um when we started that was
really neat. Uh uh you said there was a
lot of natural disasters in the Bible.
Like that was a driving thing that was
happening a lot. So a lot of people have
dealt with this over the course of the
earth's history. Yeah. I mean if you
look in the Bible
and and check out different Bible
stories where God used nature to get the
attention of the Israelites, it's pretty
it's pretty fascinating. Or to get the
attention of the whole world. Um,
probably the biggest climate uh story in
the Bible is the flood. That's true.
There was a lot of rain that came and
and that was that was partially a
judgment, partially to get people's
attention to point them back to God. Um,
if you look at the story of Elijah, King
Ahab, Jezebel. Yeah. Nature. What What
did God do? Took away their three-year
drought, right? And what was the purpose
of that? to show him that God was the
one that controlled that, not Baal.
Right. It was getting God getting the
people's attention back to God because
Ahab, Jezebel, there had been a great
apostasy and and there had been I mean
horrible things done. If you look if you
look in those stories there their high
places were used for child sacrifice. Um
horrible things, fertility rights,
things like that that that were um that
that the Israelites were starting to
dabble with and moving in that
direction. And God God used that as a as
a way, hey, you know, I'm still here.
Remember me. And and so sometimes God
used those things to to get people's
attention back to him. And so when when
we see these things happening now and we
see that Jesus gave us a heads up, hey,
these things are going to be happening
in the time just before I come. And in
Luke, it says, "Pay attention. When
these things happen, the end is near."
Amen. I think this is this is a time for
us to to not be afraid.
Um I don't think God gives us a spirit
of fear. Whenever we go through trials
and struggles, God is going to be with
us. God was with Elijah through all that
even though he was being he was being
persecuted. Um God kept him safe and and
was with him through the whole thing.
And I believe God will do that for us as
well when we're faithful to him. It's
interesting Ahab's reaction to that. you
troubler of Israel. Like like not
thinking that this natural disaster and
what happened here now I should reflect
on what my relationship with God is like
he's like pointing the finger at Elijah
and needing to take his life because
he's the one that that you know
basically made the claim. Well, we also
know that the story of Ahab and Jezebel
and Elijah is also symbolic of what's
going to happen in the last days, but
that's a whole different study. But
there's they're symbolic. Yeah. But you
were mentioning Noah. Jesus also made a
reference back to Noah's flood and and
the state of mind of the people then um
to he said that was so as in the days of
Noah so shall the end be and we see
their mindset and what happened with the
flood came as a judgment right and so
even now God is using or not I wouldn't
say use he's allowing natural disasters
to happen to warn us of the coming
judgment that he's coming soon my
brother Brock has a ministry that he
does international search and rescue
type stuff. And they've been helping a
lot with reliefs of hurricanes and and
they just went to um the last one that
happened. I can't remember where it was.
It was like a one that wiped out this
little town. Yeah. Wiped out this little
tiny town, but flattened it. I mean,
when you see where it went through, I
mean, there was nothing left of these
houses. Not one death. Wow. And it was
people's stories of like crazy stuff.
Like all of a sudden, this guy with 5
acres saw the thing hit the ground at
the edge of his 5 acres. You got 10
seconds to figure out what you're going
to do. He ran into his house, went into
the bathroom, the entire house is swept
off the foundation, flattened to the
ground, except for the bathroom. Wow.
You know, so what's crazy is when
something like that happens, you know
what people do? Why did this happen? And
what's the bigger picture? That's that's
what's on their mind. It's like my whole
life just got swept away from me. What
am I doing? What what is what is life
about? You know, and it's a great way to
minister to them at that point. But um
yeah, we're going to see these things
get worse and worse. The world is nuts
right now. I mean, media people can't
even keep up dayto-day with all the
crazy stuff going on in the world. When
Jesus talked about wars and rumors of
wars in the time right before he comes,
you know, you look at if you if you go
and Google how many how many wars have
been in the last 10 years, there's like
this long list all over the place. even
in places where most of us in the
Western world aren't paying attention.
There's wars but skirmishes between
people back and forth. Um and and it
seems to have increased since when I was
a kid. Mhm. Mhm. A lot. Mhm. And when
when you look at that and you combine
that with all of the like the statistics
that we talked about about the increase
and all this this um tornadoes and and
weather related
stuff, it's a reminder to me that that
Jesus loves us enough to give us a heads
up and say,
"Hey, pay attention to this stuff." Mhm.
These are going to be some of the signs
that I'm coming soon. Mhm.
and and that was a big focus of his uh
before he went back to heaven. He says,
you know, I'm going to prepare a place
for you. That means each one of us has
an address in heaven. Jesus is counting
on us being in heaven. He's planning on
us being there. Amen. And he gave us all
of this stuff to have a heads up and
say, "Hey, I'm coming soon." When you
see this stuff, don't plan on staying
here longer.
Prepare your hearts to get out of here.
Look up. Look up. Don't look down. And
that's that's I think kind of with what
you were talking about. we we kind of
are are looking down a lot of times.
We're focused on work or this or that or
our problems and this is this, you know,
these different things in life, these
cares of life. But when we're looking up
Mhm. we have a lot more hope. Mhm. And
and for me, when I read this stuff,
um it's a relief for me to know that
Jesus is coming soon. I say this all the
time in my church because people ask me
this all the time. They're like, "Well,
you know, why are we still here? When is
Jesus coming? How come Jesus hasn't come
yet? And um we see all these different
signs and and whatnot. Why hasn't Jesus
come here? When is he coming? And um I
say this all the time at the end of my
sermons when I preach on Sabbath. I say
I don't know when Jesus is coming, but I
know that today we're one day closer.
Amen. And that it doesn't really matter
if it's, you know, one month, one year,
one you should be ready tonight. Yep.
Cuz you walk out this door and you
somebody smash you and you're gone. Mhm.
Yeah. I I can wrap my head around one
day. Mhm. And when I wake up tomorrow,
I'm one day closer again. Yeah. I don't
know. I don't know when that is. Yeah. I
don't know if it's a year, if it's 10
years. I don't know when it is. Mhm. But
it helps it helps me keep my focus on
what's important.
Because I know today I'm one day closer
to being with Jesus in heaven. And he's
given us and he's given us the signs for
a reason saying, "Hey, it's really close
now. Be ready." Yeah. There's, you know,
the lyrics of probably the most famous
song in the world is uh the famous
Everybody knows the song Amazing Grace.
Oh, yeah. And um it's it's kind of cool.
Amazing Grace talks about this this
topic and um in one of the verses it
says, and you this this probably will
sound familiar. It says, "The earth
shall soon dissolve like snow. Mhm. The
sun forbear to shine. Weird stuff's
going to happen. The author knew of
these prophecies in the Bible. But God
who called me here below will be forever
mine. In one of the other verses, it
says, "When we've been there 10,000
years, when we've been there, not here."
Bright shining as the sun, we've no less
days to sing God's praise than when we
first begun. Amen. This has been a
bedrock of Christianity for a long time
that we need to be looking up. Things
are going to get crazy. The Bible says
that Jesus says this. Mhm. But this is a
time and I believe the Bible teaches
that that these are the the end times
right before he's going to come back.
Mhm. Our focus needs to be on him
looking up like you said, Scotty. Amen.
Our focus needs to be on Jesus, on
sharing the gospel as it says in Matthew
24:14. I that's been kind of a theme for
my life, that one verse. Mhm. The gospel
is going to go to the whole world. Then
the end shall come. We were talking on
my on my YouTube channel. Um I'll give
it a shout out. 8:32. Yeah. Just
describe what the 8:32 is. So it's it's
a reference to John 8:32. And um uh and
so the the focus is on on getting the
gospel out as as in as many places as
you can, right? And we have the tools
now, right? And it's every all hands on
deck at this point. And so, um, you
know, on my on my channel where we're
using AI to to translate into a bunch of
different languages. So, cool. It was
really fun. I did, um, I did a three
angels messages series of, three
different videos. Um, and I had done
them in my English channel and we had
them translated into, uh, Italian. Nice.
And so, we did those three and, uh, it
was it was super fun. I ended up, you
know, with with the different views, we
did about 85,000 uh, Bible studies with
people all across Italy on the three
angels messages. Amazing. Um, I don't
speak Italian, but thanks to AI, I do
now. Yeah. So, now now the three angels
message, you need to come back. I know
we don't have time to explore this
today, but but that's something I know
you're passionate about and you talk
often about it and and we sort of our
work if you think about it too, like in
that three angels message from from, you
know, Revelation is like don't have the
character of the world, right? Get right
with God and and come out of these
systems of the world. And so, you know,
that's kind of what our ministry has has
been doing for for a long time. So, you
need to come down and break that down
for us some time. And, you know, there
there's a tie in with that, too, in what
we're talking about today because in the
three angels messages, one of the
biggest key components to the whole
thing is worship. Yeah. Worship. People
miss that. Miss that. So, let's unpack
that for a second. So, a lot of people
are are basically getting coralled with
this whole climate change and stuff like
this because I've always thought, how
are you going to get Satanists and, you
know, people that don't want religion,
people that don't care about religion,
people that are of different religions,
right? How are you going to get them all
on the same page? This is like an an
easy funnel that's basically going to
pull people into reserving that day of
worship and then eventually it will get
legislated. Yeah. and and in recognizing
authority
that can that can be a way of worshiping
and we see that in the three angels
messages. And so you're right. No matter
what people if if people acknowledge
authority Yeah. and and follow that's
that's I think a lot of what the three
angels message is talking about. Um and
and that that for sure it's a f I love
that topic. It's a fascinating topic
because I'm a bit of a history nerd too.
Nice. and and going through um Bible
prophecy, it ties in a lot with history
and and the timeline throughout the
world's history as you read it through
Bible prophecy really gives clarity to
to what God is is is telling us and
preparing us to uh to to go to heaven
with him someday and make it to these
end times. And and Daniel 11, I'm going
through it right now. Um and when you go
toward the end of Daniel 11, it also
talks about how um this religious
institution when once the image of the
be image to the beast has been made in
full and it receives a military backing,
that's when you do have these other
religions and stuff that are like look
everybody's doing it. We we have no we
can't stand against this institution and
then you have to give in. Um and that's
when we see the mark of the beast in the
hand which the Bible says is actions and
not in necessarily also in the head
which is where you make a conscious
decision with your um brain which
obviously this is the the seat of
morality and will as the frontal lobe
the frontal part of the brain anyway. So
just wanted to put that out there but
then like you said the the climate
change aspect is one of the different
flavors. Satan has multiple flavors for
everybody. And this is one of the aspect
that how he's going to try to do this or
how he is trying to do this. And and you
know, you see you see limitations
already on buying and selling in connect
in connection with this. Yeah. Um there
was just a big um a big thing I think it
was in Minnesota or North Dakota, one of
the two where they were talking about
blue laws. North Dakota. It was North
Dakota. Yeah. And there was a big
shindig on what what they were going to
be um trying to regulate. I don't think
it passed, but where I used to live in
Colorado, and here in the south too, you
still see a lot of blue laws, um there
were limitations on what you could buy
or sell on Sunday. If you wanted to buy
a car in Colorado on Sunday, you
couldn't because the auto dealers are
not allowed to be open on Sunday. Yeah.
And so you see, if you just go look up
blue laws, you'll see uh you'll see a
lot of these limitations already. And
the the purpose is is exactly what we're
seeing in some of these green sabbaths
and things like that. and the um the
ideas on giving it a rest, but it's but
it's it's slowly kind of being forced.
Um and and I always try and remind
everybody that Jesus is is he he's not
about force, right? He is about your
will in coming to him and and
surrendering that will to him. I you
know, for the last decade and a half,
I've studied media pretty impact pretty
pretty in-depthly. Yeah. And um made an
entire, you know, decade of ministry
work out of that. And and we know media
impacts us. We know we watch certain
things and and it trickles out to the
public and and the public responds to
those things, right? If you really
wanted to change things, if you really
wanted to change things for the morality
of good, right? Why doesn't the society
get together and be like, "Okay, nobody
can make movies about, you know,
killing. Nobody can make movies about
this and that. We could we could shape
society in a loving manner." But they're
not doing that. Yeah. But then it's like
we're going to get you in trouble if
you're not like doing this thing over
here with climate change, but what about
all that other filth that's out there?
Yeah. You know, it's wild. Yeah. Yeah,
it is. You know, in in the end, in this
whole in this whole conversation,
[Music]
um I see I see this this whole climate
agenda as as a distraction to biblical
truth.
And and my appeal to everybody who's
watching this is to to get to know what
the Bible says about the end of this
world. We're not going to be here
forever. We're not going to be here
forever. This this planet, even if even
if everybody went 100% green, there's no
way this planet can last forever. Right.
Right. And and Jesus tells us in
scripture what to expect. And part of
that message is is to to give your heart
to him. He's the only hope that we have
on this planet. The only hope. The the
things that this world has to offer are
shallow at best.
Not meaningful at all. Um, and and when
we have a relationship with Jesus, not
only do we experience God's love, not
only do we have purpose and hope, not
only do we have somebody who we can go
to, the Bible's full of promises that
that he'll be there and lift us up with
his righteous right arm when we're
struggling and falling, but but the best
thing and the thing that Jesus focuses
on so much is that he has a plan for us.
And that plan has nothing to do with
staying here in this current state,
right? The plan is to help to help us
escape this sinful world and live in a
place like it says in Revelation 21
where there's no more sickness, no more
sorrow, no more death, no more tears.
Mhm. I I look at that and I almost
struggle to imagine what that's like. I
mean, I I love it. I love all of it. But
we're so we're so used to that type of a
world where, you know, there's always
something Yeah. We're used to the pain.
Like, how could how do we how do we even
imagine a place where there's no
hospitals or cemeteries or never getting
sick again, you know. Yes. And I read
about it and I'm like, I want that. And
Jesus wants that for us as well. Amen.
And the hope that we have in scripture
is that there's a there's a God who
loves us, a God who cares about us, a
God who has plans for us, plans for
good, the Bible says. Mhm. And and he's
made a way for us to leave this world
and go to a place where there's no more
of of the stuff we deal with now. Yeah.
And he he set that up because he loves
us so much. Yeah. Yeah. And he cares
about us. And and that's the message
that I hang on to from the Bible. Amen.
That's the hope I have in in this world
ending. This world is not going to end
because the the temperature raises a
degree and a half. Right. This world is
going to end. The Bible says because the
gospel has been preached to the whole
world. Mhm. And everyone's had a chance
to follow Jesus and then Jesus is going
to come and take us home. Amen. Amen.
Hopefully that's real soon. Oh, I hope
it's tomorrow. Maybe this afternoon. I'd
be great if it was this afternoon.
Jamie, thank you for sharing that with
us. Honestly, you need to come back. I
would love to. Yeah. And and and say
again your um podcast 8:32, right? Yeah.
8 and then the word 30 and then two. And
uh it's on YouTube and um Tik Tok,
Instagram, all all of the all the stuff.
And uh we go through through uh Bible
studies uh going through different
topics and whatnot. And uh and so it's
it's it's a lot of fun.
and you guys. Yeah. I want to thank you
as well for for your your biblically
based and encouraging um content that
you put out. It's it's uh it's blessed a
lot of people. Um it's blessed my kids.
My kids have watched a lot of your
content and that's been that's been
formative for them in making good
decisions in life. And so I just wanted
to give you guys a shout out and say
thank you so much for all the work you
put in and pointing people to Jesus.
Thank you. That's what it's all about.
Just keep your eyes on Jesus. That's
right. You're awesome, man. We'll have
you back. All right. Thanks so much for
having me. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
And drop a comments below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. No. No. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]